Séraphine Alain
avant tout c'était des camarades
et
on va dire c'est aussi
va dans non non c'est bon
Ah bon d'accord
d'accord
mais c'est
c'est c'est des camarades mais au-delà
des camarades c'est une période c'est
une période où on
croyait cheville et au corps
lendemain qui chante et
et quelque part il y avait pas de
frontières entre les artistes et donc je
me suis retrouvé à partager des choses
avec eux et ils ont accepté de partager
des choses avec moi donc
moi je suis
un plasticien
[Musique]
alors moi je suis
je vais dire que je suis un artiste
impliqué un artiste qui a créé des
choses
qui est un plasticien donc il y a fait
autant des choses dans le domaine de la
création plastique mais je me suis
permis aussi d'être un créateur d'école
vu que j'ai fait naître école des
beaux-arts et l'Institut de l'image de
l'océan Indien voilà
mais je parlais déjà comme ça monsieur
c'est-à-dire que j'étais un créateur qui
[Musique]
essayait de penser que il y a pas de
développement sans créativité et donc
j'avais créé l'atelier pour toi qui a
précédé village Titan et qui a précédé
l'école des Beaux-Arts donc j'étais
essai et on se retrouver autour de sa
les premiers affiches sont fait à
l'atelier pour toi les premiers dès
qu'on se sont fait à l'atelier pour toi
abc tu es une ambiance où on avait
l'envie Lyon croyais un gendarme total
vous savez je vais pas trouvé de trace
là mais j'ai même
dessiner et faire des costumes pour
jusqu'à quand ils ont été un soir à dans
le comedia à Champfleury
costume et et
il représentait un peuple en devenir qui
s'appellent les métisses sable et qui
font partie de mon univers donc on a
partagé des choses ils ont accepté ce
type de jeu et il y a eu des affiches il
y a eu des décors
et il y a eu des temps
d'échange en quelque sorte on va dire
moi c'est il y a plusieurs on va dire il
y a il y a Rico
c'est une chanson assez christique
et j'avais fait une petite illustration
de Rico qui est comme une une animation
on a quelques traces c'était des
aquarelles je n'imaginais pas un jour
fait un être une industrie de cinéma
d'animation à la Réunion et voilà c'est
fait vu que mes Rico été la première
trace et et je pense que cette chanson
qui
qui reste
optimiste parce qu'il fallait faire il
fallait qu'il il se réveille
c'était c'était un cri d'espérance donc
pour moi c'est cette chanson est une
belle chanson et une chanson d'espoir
alors que c'est une chanson de douleur
voilà
comment
ah moi je ne suis pas chanteur donc
jeune je ne vais pas m'aventurer sur ce
terrain-là
je ne vais pas m'aventurer de chaussures
et par contre
il y a aussi Pays-Bas tofu
mais je pense que Pays-Bas tofu et tu
n'as pas de temps c'est un temps pour
elle est peut-être correspond est
d'actualité aujourd'hui
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'on est
dans un pays bateau fou et
parce que
aujourd'hui plus que jamais il faudrait
chanté cette chanson
pour que les Réunionnais prenne
conscience de l'importance
on est dans un monde où l'humanité se
tirer des balles dans le pied on est
nous on est là et Neo carrefour et de
culture et de temps en temps je vois des
choses où on a l'impression de marcher
sur la tête et et
j'aimerais que cette période où on avait
la fois cette période où on avait le
rêve pour nous cette période où on
pouvait se projeter
dans un avenir meilleur
soit de nouveau là et je pense que pour
moi jusqu'à quand c'était aussi ça qui
fait que on sait apprécier en en tant
qu'artiste même si moi j'étais pas du
domaine de la musique mais j'étais
domaine de l'aspiration plastique on
s'est rencontrés sur cette envie de
croire en allant de mes deux meilleures
voilà actualités
c'est ça qui devrait être d'actualité
pour les Réunionnais existent qu'à quand
était un reflet de d'un engagement d'une
jeunesse de d'une époque qui croyais que
c'était le monde de la culture était un
mon engagé
je veux dire on n'était pas dans le
milieu culturel
comme ça on était dans ce milieu
culturel avec l'envie
de dépeindre cette à venir qu'on qu'on
voulait meilleur voilà
bien sûr
non je
sais c'est un plaisir d'être là c'est un
plaisir de voir que les camarades malgré
nos âges on a pas beaucoup vieilli et
[Rires]